hey i'm paul booth tattoo artist today
i'm going to share some of my horror
stories with you
when i first started tattooing i had a
guy he was drunk
but i didn't know he was drunk he passed
out so i went and got my mentor and i
said this guy is unconscious what do i
do
and he said well you might as well keep
tattooing him and when he wakes up it'll
be done seemed weird but i guess it made
sense
so i went on to tattoo him while he was
unconscious and next thing i know
after like five minutes picks up his
head and projectile vomits
straight into my lap and across my
workstation and then passed out again
i was covered in vomit i had to hose
everything down in my room and
no don't tattoo drunks because that's
what happens
hi i'm fan i'm from bristol tattoo it's
a vegan shop in brooklyn
it was summertime and the guy came into
the shop
and he wants to get a small number
on his rib here i asked him to put on
like this placement
the second he opened his arm like that
i'm like
dude you should have take a shower
before coming to get a tattoo
i'm almost passed out it's the worst
experience
like a like a
chemical destroy
weapon and the second one is also the
smell
there's a girl she's cute and
she wants to get a custom piece
on the back of her cart and
i asked her to take off her shoe because
i have to check the placement
and the second she took off her shoes
it's also in summer time i was like
okay it's like
smells like a
dead fish
it's so terrible and lucky
she just laid down on her stomach and
she cannot tell my face but i have to
bear the smell for like maybe two hours
around
and the first hour i was like i'm dying
but
the last hour i was just like oh
i'm getting into the smell
like i'm like i guess i cannot smell
anything
else just her feet the smell will never
makes you forget i hope only me
have this worst experience it won't
happen
to any artists i hope you
will get lucky yeah i just i recommend
every single person
getting take a shower before you get
your tattoo
i appreciate that take a shower
[Music]
you